Karen mornin of la talk radio's film
courage and we're in the beautiful
studio of la talk radio here and as we
walked in this morning we found these
great little treats here and we've
affectionately named this the Gregory
bein white chocolate mustache since we
get that on Greg remain calm and then we
have our wonderful goodbye promise back
or Paul bourgogne and this is a halt
bourgogne butterscotch treat so check it
out we have the two gentlemen here in
studio and actually Paul bourgogne is
going to take the reins and interview
filmmaker Gregory bane I'm Paul Berg oh
yeah I'm not Gregory beans that's right
here is Gregory Bateson um I've never
done this so uh forgive me but I got
this in the studio with you today and it
was pretty educational for me you know I
learned a lot and and I just have it be
like a teacher and I won't be like what
did you learn yeah I want you to be my
sensei but um really um listen to talk
about your films Jen's Pulver driven and
perseverance and I also had a chance to
talk to you downstairs you know your
father of a six-year-old daughter and me
myself I have a sixth sixteen-year-old
daughter so I know how busy you are how
do you find the time to to to do what
you do as a filmmaker and and raise a
daughter engage your out your audience
that you're building and be creative at
the same time uh well it's definitely
obviously a challenge having
all these sort of things sort of
circulating you know I part of it well
with my daughter I you know have her
every other week so I do get a week that
I've have just that I can you know work
it's a lot of I'm kind of sleep very
well part of it but you know it sort of
has become this extension of it's just
what I do I mean I've worked serve as a
photographer and editor for the last 10
years so and now just doing my own thing
and sort of a natural extension to jest
you know I wake up every day and I you
know i'll be online for a little bit
I'll you know do what I have to do if I
have my daughter right you know get
after school then I have a couple hours
I can just sit and work it's uh but it
is it's a strain especially when you're
not only making the films but then
working on distributing the films
because there's huge amounts of things
that have to be done and i have a1
collaborator j rubin Appleman who is
sort of my main guy used wrote and
starred in person of interest and is
writing Jen's Pulver driven and also
sort of helping pick up the slack of
other things that we need to do but it
is a you know it's just one of those
things where you just kind of got to do
what you have to do and I have to
constantly sort of return emails engage
as well as take care of my own client
work as well as you know raise a child
and you know I i guess i will get it in
terms of i'm grateful that i have the
life that I have I mean a lot of people
have to go to a nine-to-fiver and do all
try you know and have the child and have
trying to figure out creative time you
know and like my entire day usually is
some level of creative time either
always paying me for it or I'm you know
investing time of my own stuff well
that's that's amazing I mean me being a
writer for the past five to six years or
so I am and raising my daughter the same
time and work in trying to bring home a
paycheck and finger is it's just that's
that sounds like a whole lot what you do
and I don't know how you do it and I'm
learning as I go so nuts inspired it's
very inspiring well thank you I I think
that oh I guess I look at it like
there's a lot of people to have a worse
off than I do and it it is a lot to do
but i feel just grateful that I have the
opportunity to actually do something and
that apparently I'm sock which is
helpful you know so it helps to sort of
keep the yeah because it is hard you
know this would be creative to
constantly be shuttered you know whether
you're doing something that's for a
client that may be sort of interesting
or not or you're doing your own work
it's it takes a lot to sort of come to
the table creatively since I think a lot
people don't realize that you know it's
one thing you know to sort of go and
have a job and have a task and you know
what that task is but I mean I'm
literally you know from ground zero
every project Ground Zero every month
you know sort of financially which is
always difficult yeah hope somebody
calls me to do someone right you know um
I was trying to think of a question in
there for you and I was kind of thinking
of when I when the day I could remember
the day I just woke up and and and
wanted to start writing and I've always
been creative throughout my whole life
but I remember waking up one day and
just so you know what this is uh I think
this I'm going to try this and I have a
story in my mind I'm going to sit down
and write it what like dude can you
remember the first time at you you know
you had like an epiphany or something
they just sat down so that this is what
I have to do and if you know if you can
remember that what
you like the courage to go through with
it for me it's a little different i
think it was actually sort of an honest
extension of my entire life I grew up in
really small rural towns I mean one time
I lived in is called Potter Nebraska and
there's literally three hundred and like
70 people in this town and so my entire
childhood was filled with comic books
and I I for as long as I can remember I
was drawing none probably like my moment
is being I think maybe seven or eight
years old and getting an award for a
picture that I drew you know and I just
like everyone in you know sort of in my
family always referred to me as the
artist in the family and that sort of
thing so I it was just a complete that
was my thing I always drew I always was
the guy in class that was the artist so
it is sorted and then when it sort of
switched over to film and try and figure
that out it was all sort of a natural
extension it was never it's always been
in my mind that oh I will do something
creative like I never had you know I've
worked regular jobs I've done all that
but it was never distant from myself
that oh I am a creative person this is
what I do you know right so it was it
sort of been the entire life which again
this and I sort of feel grateful about
and it would I don't you know I didn't
have anybody my family that was overly
creative my grandfather was and he was a
great storyteller and I think that
probably influenced me a lot but I mean
a lot of it was being in small towns
with no entertainment direct comic books
you